Peggy's 16 what in God's name is this  some sort of abandoned ship what you  taking up where are you taking me my  question I'm sorry  why would they be chained and locked oh  you my [ __ ] no such thing as ghosts  there are ghosts now somebody's hashtag  basic husband  be my best buddy I be fine see I'm not  fine I was about to have a heart attack  family just turned into a zombie who did  bread I'm Brad  oh don't grab my buck when I turn around  today just get really lucky Oh  epic gamer moment it's okay I live  because I suck they could still be like  this game  when that motion Kafka twist at Taco  Bell  I just saw someone in the woods ah  whoever it was they're gone  okay very good  you see  [Music]  let's see us a nightly show no a vixen  factory to me  you  [Music]